we'll get through this champions club
that's I know it's a tough that's life's
weird right now I will get through this
okay and [__] what's up guys is keeping
score eSports and let's cut to the chase
everybody's got the same question on
their mind what the hell is going on
with doctor disrespect well we went live
early this week over on our twitch
channel to talk about everything going
on with this news
Colin Dimitri Davin and I went deep on
what we think happened whether we think
he's actually banned for life and what
we think he did you don't want to miss
this one if we're gonna talk about doc
like we need to ground ourselves we need
to start from the beginning because it's
only been like what like 72 hours but
it's been crazy so far so Keith I would
definitely appreciate it if you could
just start at where it started right and
go from there
okay so on Friday I believe we had this
tweet from slasher who obviously is
someone we get a lot of breaking eSports
news from and it just says flat out
sources doctor disrespect has been
permanently banned from twitch after
that there was a bunch of speculation
about what was going on and why it
happened we saw an advertisement with
his sponsor or previous sponsor or
whatever we're not 100% sure game feel
we're yeah they had previously had a
photo of doctor disrespect on their
Twitter and took it down and then put it
back up and now it's down again and
people were like you know maybe there's
if it was some validity here
- what slash it was saying and then we
had you know some follow-up reports a
report from kotaku pc gamer you know the
normal written reports when it comes to
gaming news with quotes from twitch that
basically said doc had violated Terms of
Service and that was basically all we
got from the situation you know there
was a there was Terms of Service banned
just like just like any other person
that gets banned on twit
you know when doc blended into the
bathroom on stream or you know when xqc
you know does something twitch doesn't
like there's a turn Terms of Service ban
and twitch kind of gets to decide how
long they get banned for ah there's no
questions in the chat like which Terms
of Service though and yeah that's
obviously the trick with an overarching
large document like Terms of Service
it's so broad and there are lines in
there that are very much along the lines
of you know we can do things at our
discretion the whole sort of strength of
that kind of system is that they don't
have to it doesn't Telegraph what a
person has done right twitch can pretty
much keep it in their black box keep it
masked if they choose to do so I think
it's worth noting that slasher replied
to his original tweet on Friday and said
that according to his sources the ban
does is nothing to do with a DMCA so
recently there's been a controversy in
twitch obviously where people have been
getting DMCA notices for using
copyrighted music as part of their
streams and slasher has indicated that
according to his sources that's not the
case when it comes to dog the next thing
we see is from Doc's wife on Instagram
where she posts a photo with some text
here I'll bring it up for you guys right
now says the outpouring of love support
strength and kindness from the arena has
truly been overwhelming you all have
made my heart full and I cannot thank
you enough no better out there than the
CC you guys are amazing much love to you
all and you know slosher took that off
Instagram and posted it restock the
views because this is the first we're
hearing from dogs can't obviously
nothing specific here at all no
reasoning no explanation just thank you
for all the support what I saw were
where people were kind of theorizing
some stuff based off of the fact that
she didn't mention doc specifically at
all mm-hmm which I thought was a bit
much personally my personal take on that
is that we shouldn't be jumping off
based on the fact that she didn't
venture
and you know guy be more doctor
disrespect I think that's a little bit
much because she does specifically call
to the champions club
so his in other words his fan base you
know his his support base out there in
the wide world
and I think using that kind of
terminology takes a little bit of the
wind out of the sails of people saying
oh well you know she didn't call him out
by name so there's got to be something
between them I personally I think that's
a bit much I mean in a situation like
this I mean you know we're all human
everybody loves a little bit of the you
know the drama the gossip or whatever
everybody feeds into it a little bit but
I think that there was definitely some
speculation that was taken to a level
that was maybe a little bit too far
especially with that post which he
mostly just like net positive trying to
like say something and then we got a
post which was very similar from doctor
disrespect himself right here where he
says champions club which has not
notified me on the specific specific
reason behind their decision firm
handshakes to all for the sport or in
this difficult time
doctor disrespect and then you have guys
from the streaming community actually
see god mode cloaks he love you keep
your head up or whatever you know a lot
of a lot of support for doc on this on
this post because you know presumably
like most of us nobody really knows
what's actually going on here so that's
kind of the the extent of the official
communication a lot of people have been
talking about we've been talking about
in the office since regarding the
specific wording there and somebody
asked in twitch chat
does he even even he does not know why
he was banned right question mark and
that is obviously how you would read
that statement upon first glance but
Keith is it possible that based on the
specific wording there's actually a bit
of a gray area there yeah so I think
it's fair to interpret this or at least
when I read this I see it and I go well
twitch has not notified me on the
specific reason behind their decision
and based on you know mine and call and
in Devon's reporting on twitch that
seems reasonable to me it seems
reasonable that
which would not say to him here is
explicitly what you did to get banned or
hears explicitly what we think you
violent how you violated to us that
seems completely in line with twitch but
when you look at this a little closer I
do think that it's worth pointing out
that the fact that twitch has not
notified him on the specific reason
behind their decision does not mean that
doc is not aware of the specific reason
it doesn't mean that like he didn't do
something worthy of this and then know
why that would have happened you know
what I mean like if I do something wrong
and I get fired for it for example I
know what I did wrong even if they say
oh well we just found that your your
behavior wasn't up to snuff so we fired
you I know that that action that crossed
a line or whatever and I'm not saying
for sure that than anything like that
happened here with Doc but all what I
think it's important to note is that
this statement doesn't necessarily mean
that doc doesn't know what's going on it
does mean that twitch doesn't or he's
saying that twitch didn't notify him but
I think that to say that doc is sitting
at home like what happened I think would
be a little bit of a stretch one it's
kind of hard just to play devil's
advocate super quickly it's it is also
possible that that wording wasn't as
calculated as we think and he doesn't
know it is possible of course one of the
interesting things just to jump off that
Keith that I saw kind of come out of the
official reporting quote-unquote from
slasher and other journalists and other
multiple people are including popular
streamers
with slasher said like hey according to
my sources they have told me the reason
why she's been banned but I don't feel
comfortable at this time officially
stayed in that on the record like this
is a lot bigger than just hey here's why
he's banned like the implication being
maybe there's some legal things that we
need to suss out before we can actually
accurately report on this and I thought
that was an important kind of
distinction that happened over the
weekend because a lot of people were
like why aren't you telling us what
happened if you know and slashers whole
point was like well there's a lot of
things going on behind the scenes that
we need to get right or I need to get
right as a journalist
or I can come forward with what I what
with what I know right or what I've been
told what what slosher is saying and you
see the tweet here is that you know just
because you're told what's happening and
that you trust the source doesn't
necessarily mean that it's it's your
prerogative to make it public you know
you have to protect your sources you
know what what if it what if slasher
said what happened or what didn't happen
and that puts it ever told him at risk
so there's a lot there's a lot more
going on here then like just get
information and post tweet you know like
you got to do a lot more than that to
make sure that this stuff is you know
all all solid a lot of times for a story
this big you're gonna want multiple
confirmed sources before you go go live
with this kind of thing there's been
reports that his discord partnership has
been removed there have been reports
that his twitch subscribers have been
refunded which in my experience covered
covering twitch is quite new this isn't
something they do to every band streamer
when when somebody gets banned for a
month they're they're not you know
refunding their entire subscription base
for that one no that's huge there's also
reports that his emotes have been
removed from twitch which would which
would be in line with his account being
bad and there's also been reports on
Twitter that twitch has gone back and
removed integrations between doc and
twitch from their social media history
so you know if they tweeted at him or
did a video with him or whatever and I
think what's what's important to
remember here is that doctor disrespect
was a partnered stream he had any and he
signed an exclusivity contract with
twitch not too long ago you remember
that kind of wrestling asked video that
he put out put out where he's flying in
from from the sky towards the twitch
logo
[Music]
well yeah I mean we've seen reports that
he was being paid like millions right
like this just wasn't some contract this
was a big deal at the we're talking you
know in line with the contracts of the
Tim's obviously ninja was the big one
for mixer but the terms and the shrouds
and the pokey means and the doctor lupus
that have signed contracts lyric Josh oh
gee like you know summit these are you
know big names and they all got a lot of
money and and that's a pretty serious
commitment to to have to give up on you
know just months later so that kind of
kind of was in line with with the
severity of the situation that people
started to feel and just doesn't it if I
can give an example chief as to the
severity of something where twitch would
refund donations and before I say this
again like we iterated off the top we
have no idea what happened so this is
not a one-to-one comparison but we made
that don't at me about zillion okie
who's the streamer back in the day who
faked a disability yeah and their money
from his audience and when he was found
out twitch banned him and refunded
subscriptions yeah so that level of
action is potentially what we're looking
at but it yeah like yeah in terms of a
historical comparison that's one of the
only times I can ever remember twitch
making the decision to refund donations
so right it's also a TV show is there
not yeah he signed a he signing a deal
to develop a television show based
around his character and I haven't as of
right now I haven't read anything that
that's been cancelled but it would be
interesting just to follow up on that
and see what happens there yeah I just
ran a search I haven't seen anything yet
but Skybound you know so yeah we knew
that that was coming obviously we
there's no like direct information yet
whether that has been impacted by
whatever is going on here but I mean
that's that's another thing that's sort
of up in the air now obviously right now
we're in a very very critical time in
the gaming world where you know a lot of
a lot of brave people are coming forward
with accusations and of alleged sexual
assault and kind of this this toxic
culture and gaming and eSports and
streaming
given the timing of this announcement a
lot of people speculated that this move
could have had something to do with with
that sort of movement that's happening
happening on the side and I mean
personally I was like that was the first
thing I thought it was like oh maybe
maybe maybe it's this now obviously we
have no idea now Colin I know that you
had a you had another another sort of
thread of speculation that that you
looked into a little bit over the
weekend oh yeah Twitter yeah one of the
whatever you want to call it conspiracy
theories or a particularly appropriate
label in this case or you know just just
theories about what happened to dog he's
regarding some of the stuff he was
talking about in his last dream
slasher pointed it out but someone else
did before him I believe someone else
someone on Twitter pointed out that in
his last stream he talked a bit about a
guy called David Icke and this is
available to view out there the clip is
definitely out there easy for you to
find
so basically doc in the last little part
of his last dream was talking about how
he won't watch the Netflix documentary
on a gentleman called David Icke and
then he then Doc proceeded to kind of um
paint David Icke in a in a favorable
light and say things to the effect of
you know it's about expanding your mind
or looking at truth or waking up and
he's kind of cool you should check him
out and I bought his book and I liked
his documentary and I kind of dig the
guy right it was along those lines yeah
David Icke yes Alex yes I like him a
little documentary on him it's pretty
enlightening
also it allows you to do is this sort of
like you know allows you to step outside
of the box just a little bit whether
some of the stuff is not true or not
whatever I think the whole the whole
goal though is to wake up and if you
don't know who David Icke is David Icke
is you know you have to call him a
fringe conspiracy theorist there's
really no other way to describe this guy
this guy for the last thirty years
pretty much exactly thirty because he
had a very famous interview in 1990
where this all popped off he has been
the poster child for insane lizard-men
conspiracy theories basically this dude
legit believes that the world is ruled
by a cabal of half lizard half alien
people who control everything and who
are the spawn of an Internet
interdimensional alien race called the
archons or the Annunaki if this all
sounds like terrible fanfiction to you
well this is literally what this guy
believes the you know it's not
figurative he believes it and here's the
Pierce a problem with that it all sounds
harmless right now but but the problem
is that David Icke has been accused over
the years several times of espousing
anti-semitic beliefs okay and of and
accused of being a Holocaust denier okay
and in some of his writings for example
he supports the existence of a document
called the I think it's called the
protocols of the Elders of Zion which is
a forged fake document from a hundred
years ago that is an anti-semitic in
nature the the thought process behind
all this what I'm getting at is that is
it possible that dr. disrespect in his
last dream by painting the sky in a
positive light by saying I bought his
book go buy his book go watch his
documentary
he's a good guy learn from him is he
promoting someone who promotes hate
speech right is is he that is that's the
question yes the question
and twitch has every right within their
TOS to disallow someone from speaking
about these kind of issues if it
certainly and certainly if they they
think it falls under hate speech so you
know it makes one wonder was that the
reason he was banned and would that get
you a perma ban on its own probably not
but remember that doc has had a series
of escalating bans in the past this is
just not his first go around the
merry-go-round and it is possible that
this was a straw that broke the camel's
back
that this that one more band no matter
what it was for maybe it was for
promoting hate speech you know if these
people's theory is correct would result
in a permanent ban so I thought that was
a pretty interesting line of thought and
I and I'll be honest with you guys when
I watch the clips I was really shocked
uh uh because I know who David Icke is
and I did seen a couple things that he's
done and I was really really shocked to
see doc borderline promoting the guy
well and Colin to your point I think you
hit it right because doc had two strikes
and so in terms of punishment from
twitch so it's not like what he did
wrong need to be sorry bill
sorry Devon just to be clear for those
of you don't know we twitch has made it
clear in the past that they have a
strike system and that each time you
break to you ass or do something that
twitch doesn't like you get a strike and
three strikes you're in and you
theoretically though that would mean the
banning of your account permanent
suspension and everything yep but
basically that right and so it didn't
need this third strike didn't need to be
something illegal or heinous or
completely over-the-top it could have
just been the fact that he was
reiterating and spouting this kind of
fringe conspiracy theorist nonsense for
twitch to be like alright that's it but
in saying that the one thing that gives
me pause there is just kind of how hard
twitch has gone to remove
from the platform's presence in turn
right refunding subs and like scrubbing
them from social media and like that
just doesn't seem to me like something
where like it seems a little more
egregious than just that but it is bad
Khan I'm with you on that there's one
more big piece of speculation that you
know I've seen a little bit on Twitter
and you know we talked about a little
bit earlier this morning and you know we
all know that doc has a flair for the
dramatic to say the least that it's
definitely he's definitely really owned
his character over the years and he's
not it's not uncommon for him to to kind
of get involved in a publicity stunt so
one thing that we're throwing around
this morning is what if that's what this
is what if doctor just respect he's
putting on a show what if what if he's
doing this as some sort of you know
human event where he's it's kind of like
it's kind of fitting faking it or not
faking it but trying to put on a show
for everybody there is no [__] way
that this is a publicity stunt like let
me just say that again there's no
[__] way
like to do this at this time in the
social site Geist with the movements
that are happening now for racial
equality for sexual equality
you know everything for police brutality
to do that right now would be the worst
calculated marketing ploy in recent
memory so I mean I'm saying there's a
ninety-nine point in finit nines chance
that this is not a publicity stunt so I
don't want to see any more about that on
Twitter like for me look I don't know
exactly what happened and I'm not going
to speculate about what I think happened
because I don't think it's healthy like
I think adding fuel to the fire is its
kind of unhealthy in situations like
this but I do I do get a sense of
severity like the
the whole refunding and and and deleting
its emotes and stuff like that that
that's like what kind of makes my makes
gets me a little bit worried because I'm
like oh man this seems like seems severe
and and it's really hard to take your
mind from oh this is severe and figure
out exactly where to go with it so
honestly we're just gonna have to wait
and see like I don't think twitches I
mean I'm not I don't think twitch is
gonna come out and say it so I'm not
sure where it will come from maybe you
know maybe will come from slasher at
some point but yeah it's it's a it's
it's really quite quite a complicated
and difficult to understand situation
well a lot of people in chatter are
pointing out and we touched on this
briefly but just to underline it a bit
more appointing out how weird the ending
to hit his last dream was yeah these
team but sort of like be taken out of
character or out of the moment
excuse me he looked at his phone that
you know you could infer that maybe he
saw something on there that kind of
shook him out of out of the moment and
then you know he ended his dream with
he's sort of like disjointed comments
about like we'll get through this it's a
tough time it was really strange we'll
get through this champions klutz but I
know it's a tough that's life's weird
right now I will get through this okay
and I mean I guess the elephant in the
room when it comes to Doc is you know
did he did he do something as some
people on Twitter on Reddit and other
platforms allege that could possibly
have been criminal in nature
because a lot of the what we discussed
today is that a lot of the things that
have happened to him via twitch are
somewhat unprecedented like the sort of
wiping of history yeah um which you know
sort of I think logically leads one to
think well you know perhaps it isn't
just a case of escalating bands and this
was the straw that broke the camel's
back which is what we talked about we
talked about the David Icke stuff
perhaps this is actually a bigger than
everything else
kind of situation and there is a ton of
speculation out there and that's all it
is right now it's complete and utter
speculation you know it is the elf in
the room we have to put it out there and
we also have to say we just don't know
maybe it's because he talked about a
crazy conspiracy theorist who you know
has been accused of being a Holocaust
denier onstream maybe it's because of
that maybe it's because he broke
something in his contract and and it is
possible it is within the realm of
possibility that it is something more
serious and that's what the speculation
is about based on the consequences he's
faced with twitch the scrubbing of
history and the silence from his camp
for the relative silence thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages